tick-tock is the latest app to soar in
popularity chances are you may have
downloaded the app to try out a new
recipe learn the latest viral dance or
maybe curious about what all the hype is
about kate houston spoke to a las vegas
tick-tock star
who is using her platform to support
small businesses
it's been absolutely a wild ride and i
don't take it for granted for a single
second
talia edgarlin never expected that her
tick tock page talls would grow
so quickly i had one video that took off
and i realized like oh my goodness
i think i could actually do this nearly
200 000 followers and four and a half
million likes later
edrilyn is now a go-to restaurant
influencer for las vegas locals
i get this comment all the time i've
lived in vegas for this amount of years
i lived in vegas for my entire life and
i did not know this place existed and
i feel like we need more people to like
let
the public know all these amazing places
that we have here after a difficult year
for the restaurant industry this app is
helping bring in customers one video at
a time
we have to close early because we sold
out everything
jackie tang owns chill house in the
northwest valley which was featured on
edrilyn's account a few months ago
after it was posted sales tripled and
lines were out the door
during the pandemic you know i worry
every day
you know if i'm going to have people
come in with
thai tic toc posting it was it revived
you know my confidence in the business
and you know
it actually works and even now tang says
the hype hasn't stopped
i still have people like they come in
they pull up their phone with
the image from take time and say hey i
want to have this strings
can i order i said yeah of course in
addition to edgeline's personal page
she's made tick-tock her full-time job
running seven other accounts for
businesses in the area kate houston
8 news now as talia's tick-tock page
keeps growing she plans to take her
talents to youtube to continue to
develop her brand